foreign
I'm a lawyer
um and I represent uh Rebecca Martin
mother of Sophie and wife Lee
Washington family and the shepherd
family and I may read this statement on
their behalf
whilst today marks the end of this
inquest it will never mark the end of
the pain for all of our families and
loved ones
nothing will ever been bring back Sophie
Lee Stephen or Kate
on the 12th of August 2021 Our Lives
will change forever
our hearts are still incredibly heavy
with grief
and we are struggling to come to terms
of our loss
we will never be able to understand or
comprehend why Davidson did what he did
it was an act of Pure Evil
however
we now know that this evil Act was
facilitated and enabled by a series of
failings and incompetence from the
people and organizations
that are supposed to keep us safe
the system has hopelessly failed us
in particular the Devon and Cornwall
police force has failed us
the evidence we have heard during this
inquest over the past five weeks is a
consistent story of individual failures
breathtaking incompetence
and systemic failings within every level
of the Firearms licensing unit of the
devil and Cornwall police
it is beyond us how Davidson a man with
a known History of Violence
mental health issues
with no real need to own a firearm was
granted a license to possess a gun in
the first place
Davison then brutally battered to
innocent children in an assault in the
park
Davidson's brutal attack
was incorrectly categorized as a
low-level assault
following this attack his firearms
license was revoked and his gun was
seized
despite being charged with violently
assaulting two innocent children
unbelievably he was given his license
and his gun back
Davidson was considered
to be a low risk by the Devon and
Cornwall police
the evidence that we have heard from
Devon called Cornwall police
was that of a system
there was a shambles from the top to the
bottom
those in charge of making decisions
as to who should possess a gun had no
training on how to do their job
there was no supervision of those
individuals
there is no auditing of the decisions
that were being made
there was a culture of granting people
Firearms licenses against the background
of serious concern
Davidson's case was a prime example
these systemic failings in Devon and
Cornwall police have failed to protect
the public
they have failed to protect our loved
ones
we firmly believe these phones at Devon
Cornwall police have resulted in the
deaths of our loved ones
so far there's been very little evidence
of regretal remorse in the decisions
actions omissions or catastrophic
mistakes made by Devon corn with police
is firearms and explosives unit multiple
other agencies care services and
individuals
warning signs were ignored and a license
to Kill was granted
senior police officers have given
evidence during this inquest seeking to
defend the indefensible
it has been extremely difficult for us
to watch
it fell to us that senior officers from
Devon and Caldwell Police
closed ranks during this inquest process
it is too late for an apology from Devon
and Cornwall police
the time for that has passed
we want accountability ownership and
change
we are very grateful to the jury and for
their findings
we thank them for the diligent and
sensitive way
they have conducted themselves during
the course of this inquest
we now want seismic change and a
complete overhaul of the Firearms
licensing system and legislation in
England and Wales
the current system and any perceived
changes since this attack does not
reassure us and it should not reassure
the public
during the next few weeks we will be
United in our commitment to making sure
the fundamental changes are made the way
Firearms are licensed in England and
Wales
we've worked with our legal team and
addressed the coroner on our thoughts on
how to prevent future deaths
we hope that change can come so no other
family has to endure the torment of what
we have been and still are going through
we would like to thank all the people
who have supported us during the worst
time of our lives
we especially like to thank the local
community and well-wishers who have made
contact from all over the world
their support and kind words made a
positive impact during a difficult time
we would also like to specifically thank
the senior coroner Ian Arrow his Council
Bridget Dolan Casey for the sensitive
way within which they have conducted
this inquest
finally we have suffered intrusion in
our lives on in an unprecedented scale
from complete strangers since the events
of the 12th of August 2021
we respectfully asked the media who are
assembled here today
and those from afar that we are now left
alone to digest and process the outcome
of this inquest
thank you